Vladimir Putin lleva años alimentando la
idea de una Rusia otra vez grande y poderosa.
En la Rusia actual cosas como la prosperidad,
el nivel de vida o el bienestar son secundarias.
Lo que importa, lo que realmente importa es
la imagen de poder.
Lo hemos visto con la terrible ira que Putin
ha desatado en Ucrania. Dónde no tenía nada
que ganar excepto la narrativa.
Ahora bien, ¿cómo consigue Putin inocular
este sentimiento entre la sociedad rusa?¿Qué
está haciendo el Kremlin para impulsar el
patriotismo? ¿Hasta qué punto se está utilizando
para ello al Ejército?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a estas
preguntas. Pero antes, vamos a ver un poco
de historia.
¿Habéis escuchado hablar del Ejército Juvenil
de Rusia? Pues… Atentos.
[Pero, un momento antes de continuar. ¿Te
has preguntado alguna vez cuándo surgió
la industria financiera moderna? ¿Has oído
hablar de la revolución que ha supuesto la
gestión pasiva? No te pierdas el último
vídeo de Si lo Hubiera Sabido. El canal de
información financiera de Mutuactivos con
el que participamos.
Un canal en el que próximamente te contarán
cómo es la gran apuesta por la energía nuclear
que está llevando a cabo el gobierno chino.
Os dejamos el enlace en la descripción.]
Dicho esto, continuemos.
1(YUNARMIYA, EL EJÉRCITO JUVENIL)
Los años que siguieron a la caída de la
Unión Soviética fueron muy complicados para
Rusia.
El país cayó en la más absoluta ruina:
la inflación se disparó, el rublo perdió
la mayor parte de su valor y las joyas de
la corona del tejido económico se las apropiaron
los oligarcas.
Hablamos de unas dificultades también alcanzaron
al Ejército.
Las fuerzas armadas rusas quedaron en evidencia
tras su intervención en Georgia en el año
2008. Aquello fue un auténtico punto de inflexión.
Tal y como os contamos en un reciente vídeo
sobre las fortalezas de Rusia - os dejo el
link en la descripción - tras esta guerra
Putin puso en marcha una profunda reforma
militar.
Para lo cual el presidente ruso contó con
una importante ayuda:
El precio del petróleo estaba batiendo todas
sus marcas históricas y llenando con ello
las habitualmente exiguas arcas del Kremlin.
Ya no había que escatimar, así que el gasto
militar ruso se duplicó aproximadamente entre
los años 2005 y 2018.
Y aunque no hay cifras confirmadas oficialmente,
los expertos señalan que el gasto militar
ruso, el gasto de verdad supera los 50 mil
millones de dólares anuales. aproximadamente
un 4% del PIB ruso.
(Durante la última década Rusia ha realizado
un importante esfuerzo de inversión en nuevos
equipos. Por ejemplo, durante este tiempo
se incorporaron a las fuerzas armadas más
de 600 nuevos aviones, 840 helicópteros y
2.300 drones. El Kremlin ha renovado el 70%
de sus cazas y el 27% de sus blindados.
Asimismo, la industria militar rusa también
ha desarrollado nuevas capacidades tecnológicas.
En esta línea, se considera que las herramientas
de guerra electrónica de Rusia, que pueden
usarse para interceptar o bloquear las comunicaciones
y drones del enemigo, no tienen nada que envidiar
a las norteamericanas.)
Pero esperad un momento, porque al Gobierno
de Putin todavía le han sobrado unos cuantos
millones para hacer otro tipo de cosas.
Por ejemplo, desde el año 2021 está en marcha
un programa de 4 años dotado con 185 millones
de dólares con un único objetivo: aumentar
la educación patriótica de los rusos.
Sí, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
Entre otras cosas, estos planes incluyen hacer
que al menos 600.000 niños se unan a las
filas del Yunarmiya, el Ejército Juvenil
de Rusia.
Pueden entrar a formar parte de él desde
los 8 años hasta la mayoría de edad.
Desde luego el Yunarmiya es un digno heredero
de los Jóvenes Pioneros de la era soviética.
Y es que, veréis, la Organización de Pioneros
Vladimir Lenin fue la organización juvenil
que utilizó la Unión Soviética para promover
los principios ideológicos del comunismo.
Existió entre 1922 y 1990 y agrupaba a niños
y niñas de entre 10 y 15 años. Alcanzó
los 25 millones de miembros en los años 70.
La organización contaba con los llamados
Palacios de Pioneros. Servían de centros
de reunión dónde los Jóvenes participaban
en juegos, trabajos manuales y algunas actividades
deportivas. Luego, en las vacaciones de verano
estos jóvenes acudían a los Campamentos
de Pioneros.
Vamos, que eran como los scouts pero con la
hoz y el martillo en la mochila.
Pero ahí no terminaba todo.
Al cumplir los 15 años, los Pioneros ya podían
formar parte del Komsomol, otra organización
para jóvenes que les servía como puerta
de entrada al Partido Comunista.
Eso sí, respecto a la época soviética,
el Yunarmiya de Putin no tiene vínculos con
el comunismo sino que se ha convertido en
una organización enfocada sobre todo al Ejército.
En ella pone especial énfasis en el patriotismo
y en el servicio a las fuerzas armadas con
un programa de entrenamientos que dirigen
oficiales de la reserva.
Es más, es que el Yunarmiya tiene incluso
su propio uniforme.
(El uniforme del Yunarmiya es la clásica
indumentaria militar de color caqui pero con
un elemento muy característico en la cabeza.
Sus miembros lucen boinas rojas con una insignia
en la que figura el logotipo del Yunarmiya:
Ni más ni menos que la estrella roja del
ejército ruso superpuesta en la cabeza de
un águila. Entre las actividades que organiza
el Yunarmiya, destacan la práctica con rifles,
el aprendizaje de primeros auxilios y la lucha
con artes marciales. )
Una vez al año el Ministerio de Defensa ruso
organiza el Congreso de Yunarmiya.
Y allí, amigos, hay de todo:
Mítines nacionalistas, armas expuestas por
doquier, competiciones deportivas entre sus
miembros e incluso una feria científica para
atraer a los más cerebritos.
Y muy importante: para crear ambiente, un
DJ toca nuevas versiones de las viejas melodías
patrióticas añadiendo efectos propios del
hip-hop.
Todo con un objetivo: mostrar a los jóvenes
rusos que nada mola más que el Ejército
Juvenil. Lo tienen bien pensado.
Seguro que todo esto es más atractivo que
insistirles con el solemne juramento del Yunarmiya.
[Aviso: a continuación expondremos una versión
reducida de este juramento, no sea que la
versión completa exalte en alguno un patriotismo
ruso inusitado]
Fijaos.
C1(Juro luchar por las victorias en los estudios
y los deportes para ser un patriota y un ciudadano
digno de Rusia. Fragmento del juramento del
Yunarmiya)
Pero, un momento, amigos, porque esta no es
la única vía que el gobierno ruso está
utilizando para fomentar la educación militar
patriótica entre los más jóvenes.
También financia a entidades privadas que
organizan concursos con disciplinas tan variopintas
como el conocimiento de la historia de Rusia
y otras más útiles en un futurible escenario
bélico como la lectura de mapas o las pruebas
de tiro con armas.
Pero si hay algo en lo que el Kremlin realmente
ha puesto todo su empeño ha sido ​​en
construir algo que sea capaz de promover
el patriotismo en toda la familia.
Algo que consiga emocionar a niños y a adultos
por igual. Hablamos ni más ni menos que de
todo un parque temático.
¿Y sabéis qué? Preparad las maletas, porque
nos vamos de viaje.
2 (PATRIOT PARK: EL DISNEYLANDIA DE RUSIA)
Los niños europeos sueñan con ir a Disneyland
París. Los norteamericanos con ir a DisneyWorld
en Orlando.
Pues bien, Putin se ha propuesto que en Rusia
todos quieran ir a Patriot Park.
Y sí, está claro que lo suyo sería que
en este parque hubiera montañas rusas, pero
digamos que las intenciones del Kremlin van
por otro lado.
Estamos hablando de un parque temático militar
dedicado al Ejército ruso que se encuentra
en la localidad de Kubinka, a una hora en
coche de Moscú.
Y ojo porque el Ministerio de Defensa ruso
no ha reparado en gastos.
Para construirlo ha preparado unos 250 millones
de euros y todo está cuidado al más mínimo
detalle.
Por ejemplo, dicen que la comida consiste
en raciones del Ejército - y claro ahí uno
se pregunta si realmente hace falta tanto
nivel de realismo.
Sea como sea, lo cierto es que el parque está
pensado para el disfrute de toda la familia.
Aunque, como suele pasar con este tipo de
instalaciones, una vez más la idea es impresionar
sobre todo a los más jóvenes. Eso sí, al
mejor estilo de la Rusia de Putin.
En este parque los jóvenes pueden participar
en actividades completamente diferentes a
las que estamos habituados a ver en los parques
de atracciones.
Por ejemplo, es probable que los chavales
estén hartos de jugar a videojuegos bélicos
con unos gráficos increíbles, pero videojuegos
en cualquier caso.
Así que poder tocar un arma de verdad e incluso
realizar algún que otro disparo es todo un
reclamo.
Tampoco hay que menospreciar otras actividades
como conducir virtualmente un tanque, utilizar
una impresora 3D o participar en el entrenamiento
de perros adiestrados.
(Además, en EL Patriot Park los visitantes
pueden ver de cerca un montón de tanques,
vehículos de transporte blindados o sistemas
de lanzamiento de misiles de todas las épocas…
Digamos que se hace un recorrido completo
por la historia bélica de Rusia.
Y ojo porque el Patriot Park también es un
lugar para los negocios. Año tras año el
parque acoge una nueva edición del Foro Army.
Se trata de un evento internacional en el
que Rusia exhibe sus últimos juguetitos militares.)
Por supuesto, sin perder detalle están siempre
las delegaciones extranjeras enviadas por
los amigos de Putin.
Al fin y al cabo los principales compradores
de armas rusas son bien conocidos: La India,
Vietnam, China y Bangladesh en Asia; Irán
e Irak en Oriente Medio; Argelia y Egipto
en África y Nicaragua y Venezuela en América.
En cualquier caso está claro que este tipo
de foros siempre son un buen lugar para hacer
business.
(Rusia utiliza una exposición de defensa
para intentar impulsar las ventas de armas
a Oriente Medio)
¿Queréis un ejemplo? Pues fijaos:
Arabia Saudí y Emiratos Árabes Unidos tienen
mucho interés por las armas rusas. Digamos,
quean tenido algunos problemas para comprarlas
en otros países por la guerra de Yemen.
Así que se dejaron caer por aquí a ver qué
podían pillar. Pero eso es otra historia.
Porque la auténtica finalidad de esta instalación
es lograr que los rusos contemplen todo el
poderío de sus fuerzas armadas.
Por supuesto, la victoria en la Segunda Guerra
Mundial, que ellos conocen como la Gran Guerra
Patriótica, es con diferencia el principal
argumento con el que se apela a las emociones
de los visitantes. Hace años organizaron,
incluso, una gran recreación de la toma del
Reichstag.
Además, en el parque también hay un museo
interactivo que se llama “1418 pasos para
la victoria”. Estos son precisamente los
días que transcurrieron desde que Hitler
declaró la guerra a la Unión Soviética
hasta el momento en que Alemania se rindió.
Y sí, ya sé lo que estáis pensando, pero
bueno Alberto, qué museos hay en cada pueblo,
por qué tanto interés en éste.
Pues fundamentalmente porque todavía no os
he hablado de lo más importante de Patriot
Park. Algo que nos dice mucho de cómo es
la Rusia de nuestros días. Me estoy refiriendo
ni más ni menos que a la Catedral de las
Fuerzas Armadas Rusas.
(La Catedral de las Fuerzas Armadas Rusas
se consagró en 2020 para conmemorar el 75
aniversario de la victoria soviética sobre
la Alemania nazi. Su exterior es como cualquier
otra catedral ortodoxa salvo por su color
verde caqui. Más interesante es su interior:
en las vidrieras las imágenes religiosas
dejan su sitio a las medallas de guerra soviéticas.
Y el diámetro de su cúpula principal es
de 19,45 metros, cifras elegidas expresamente
para simbolizar el año de la victoria.)
Amigos, hay dos detalles de esta Catedral
que son a todas luces fascinantes. El primero
es el suelo. Y no precisamente porque esté
hecho con mármol de los Urales, que no es
el caso. La cuestión es que a alguien del
Kremlin se le ocurrió fundir armas y tanques
incautados a la Alemania nazi para hacer los
suelos del templo. El objetivo es que si algún
día visitáis la Catedral de las Fuerzas
Armadas Rusas, a cada paso que deis, estéis
pisoteando al vil enemigo fascista.
ALuego, el otro elemento más destacado de
esta Catedral son sus mosaicos. Posiblemente
es uno de los templos ortodoxos que reúne
más mosaicos de todo el mundo. Pero lo que
los hace únicos es su temática.
Junto a las imágenes religiosas hay otros
mosaicos que hacen apología de la historia
reciente rusa. ¿Cómo de reciente? Bueno,
pues al final no tanto como tenían previsto.
(Rusia elimina un mosaico de Putin en una
iglesia del Ejército)
El diseño en el que estaban ya trabajando
podéis verlo en pantalla. Pero se ve que
al final les pareció un poco heavy elevar
a Putin a los altares. Al menos mientras siga
siendo el presidente del país.
Claro que el resto de mosaicos tampoco tienen
desperdicio: están dedicados a los ejércitos
soviéticos y rusos. Hay uno muy significativo
en el que dos ángeles miran desde lo alto
a un grupo de soldados con sus armas modernas.
Una lista conmemora una larga serie de conflictos:
las intervenciones soviéticas para aplastar
la revolución de Hungría, la Primavera de
Praga o la invasión de Afganistán. También
se añaden las dos guerras rusas en Chechenia
y otras misiones más recientes que la propaganda
rusa denomina como “restablecer la paz en
Georgia”, “el regreso de Crimea” y “la
lucha contra el terrorismo internacional en
Siria”.
Y, ¿sabéis qué? Otra cosa no, pero los
rusos previsores son un rato. Así que han
dejado sitio para añadir más conflictos
en el futuro. Sí, pronto se sumará Ucrania
a esta especie de recordatorio nacional.
Claro que nos falta quizás la pieza más
importante de todas.
Atentos.
3(LA FORTALEZA SITIADA)
Rusia sabe que ya no es la Unión Soviética
en tiempos de la Guerra Fría. Que ya no es
una de las dos superpotencias hegemónicas
del planeta. Pero Putin se resiste a tener
un papel secundario.
Y lo hemos visto, vaya que si lo hemos visto
en Ucrania, dónde durante meses Putin la
tuvo rodeada por tierra, mar y aire…Hasta
que finalmente atacó.
Todo para que se siga viendo a Rusia como
una gran superpotencia.
Y no perdáis de vista que Rusia ya no habla
solo de Rusia, sino también de los otros
países que formaban la órbita soviética.
De este modo el gobierno ruso lanza un mensaje
muy claro: que todo el mundo sepa que los
intereses rusos no se acaban donde terminan
las fronteras de Rusia.
Algo similar defendió a finales de enero
el propio Vladimir Vasiliev, líder parlamentario
de Rusia Unida, el partido de Putin, cuando
pidió al Kremlin apoyo para los separatistas
prorrusos del Donbass.Fijaos.
Y, ojo, porque aquí tenemos una de las grandes
claves del marketing del Kremlin.
El gobierno ruso lleva años preparando a
sus ciudadanos para el conflicto. Para ello
presenta a Rusia como la fortaleza sitiada.
Su objetivo es concienciar a los rusos de
que están rodeados de enemigos y que por
ello tienen que estar preparados para defender
a la patria. Con frecuencia incluso trazan
paralelismos con el ataque que sufrió la
Unión Soviética en la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Y claro, desde el sofá de nuestra casa podemos
pensar, ba, qué exagerado es este Putin…
Pero lo cierto es que este mensaje sí que
cala en la sociedad rusa. Vamos que si cala.
En reciente encuesta del Centro Levada de
investigación sociológica, mirad cuál es
la segunda preocupación de los ciudadanos
rusos.
Más de la mitad de los rusos tiene verdadero
pánico a la posibilidad de que haya una guerra
mundial. Ojo, No una guerra en Ucrania. ¡Una
guerra mundial!
Es evidente que la propaganda rusa en torno
a la fortaleza sitiada surte efecto.
Y por eso titulares como este siempre son
música para los oídos del Kremlin.
(Se insta a los países de la OTAN a suministrar
más armas a Ucrania)
El pretexto que Putin necesita para hacer
lo que le da la gana es el de la seguridad
y las supuestas amenazas.
Porque vamos, evidentemente la mayoría de
los rusos comunes no quieren una guerra. Los
rusos son como tú o como yo, quieren trabajar,
quieren prosperidad, quieren libertad.
Pero claro, ese patriotismo que lleva décadas
inculcando el Kremlin hace que los rusos se
sientan obligados a defender a sus hermanos
rusos del Donbass.
(El éxito de la anexión de Crimea en 2014
exaltó el patriotismo ruso. Y ya de paso
sirvió para que Putin disimulara ante los
suyos que la economía rusa ya no crecía
al mismo ritmo que a principios de siglo.
Así que, visto lo visto, no debería extrañarnos
que el Kremlin esté intentando repetir la
jugada con una Rusia golpeada por la pandemia,
la inflación y las acusaciones de corrupción.
En otras palabras, que no podemos descartar
que todo el conflicto sea una auténtica maniobra
de distracción.)
Desde luego muchos más motivos no había.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Qué pensáis del ataque a Ucrania?
Dejadnos por aquí abajo vuestros comentarios
y si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle al botón de de like y
suscribiros al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.